I just think that the the criminal line
is drawn way too far i mean my my
colleagues and friends who are in the
Chicano movements in the southwest often
say look we didn't cross the border the
border crossed us right we were here
then then America came so don't call
this immigrants well a similar thing
happened with crime right it's not so
much that we became more criminal is
that more things became criminal one way
to think about it is that during Jim
Crow right simply being black in public
space was criminal activity right so
going to a movie theater and sitting in
the downstairs instead of upstairs was a
crime right drinking out of the wrong
water fountain was a crime sitting in
the front of the bus was a crime now we
look at those things now and think well
that's that's ridiculous right the these
are clearly just patterns of people's
lives and behavior these are things that
we think of as freedom of choice and the
right to assemble and so how could we
have thought of them as criminal so the
the line of what constitutes crime is
socially constructed it can move back
and forward right my parents
relationship was a criminal relationship
in the state of Virginia where I grew up
three years before we came there so I
mean three years before we moved to
Virginia my parents relationship was in
fact a criminal relationship so what I
know for certain is that we can change
what constitutes crime and then in doing
so we don't make a world that is more
dangerous I think we actually make a
world that is more free so we can say
that we are as unconcerned with
inner-city high school kids smoking pot
at the bus stop as we are about
Princeton kids getting drunk to the
point of killing brain cells every
Thursday night we can just simply say
you know what these are not activities
that make us afraid we are not afraid of
young people we're not afraid of the
choices that they're making that we
don't have to police every single
activity to the point of incarceration
that we can't have laws on the book that
stamps sort of our our social code about
what matters
but that we do not have to police them
at the same level we don't in fact have
to kind of fill our jails with people
who are doing petty property excuse me
petty drug crime right penny drug crime
does not require the kinds of massive
incarceration that it's currently
getting we can talk about property crime
we can talk about sort of you know
physical crimes of rape and but those
things by the way have all been in
decline as we have grown our prison
population in terms of petty drug crime
there is no war on drugs there's a war
on sort of petty drug users and I think
we could we could make a choice not to
be in that war
you